welcome back to down the middle
i'm happy you're here with us today i i
have with me a mentor
the individual who inspired me to go to
wall street 25 years ago when i
graduated the mccomb school of business
we've got the stadium in the background
this is this is the the fifth
installment of the austin series um and
i cannot be any more delighted to have
dr keith brown with me here today in the
flesh i i don't you know i don't do this
down the middle rogers i have to read it
because there's so much of it so here we
go
keith brown holds the positions of
university distinguished teaching
professor and phia seraphim fellow at
the macomb school of business university
of texas austin where he specializes in
teaching investments portfolio
management security analysis capital
markets and derivatives courses i was in
the derivatives course
at the bba and mba levels he's also a
member of the university's academy of
distinguished teachers
i'm not going to read the rest part he's
i mean hicks muse i mean it just you've
been in private equity as well
uh
your co-founder and senior partner
fulcrum financial group a portfolio
management investment advisory and
business evaluation firm located here in
austin
uh and you're an advisor to the board of
trustees of the teacher retirement
system of texas which i think is the
third largest
pension in the country maybe
it depends on how you define that yes
it's up there it's top ten and you also
are an advisor to the board of directors
at the university of texas investment
management company otherwise known as
utemco
welcome
thank you very much this is this is like
i can't believe it's by the way um thank
you for the kind words in your
introduction i learned a long time ago
that if you want people to say nice
things about you you got to write the
script yourself
i love that i appreciate you reading the
script or at least some of the script
well i haven't read all of the script
though so um but anyways 25 years i mean
i can't believe it's been 25 years i
can't believe i went off to wall street
25 years ago i'll tell you a story about
that in a bit
uh that's last century right
i know wow that is some perspective oh
it's terrible so
um
so you are professor of finance were
your parents involved in the in the
business
no not at all i i don't to this day have
a great story on how i got to where i am
i couldn't kind of tell you what the
story is but
my my parents i grew up in actually in
san diego california
um
very sort of middle class background my
mom was a homemaker
after
getting a master's in english and
teaching for a while and just raised my
sister and i uh my dad was a mid-level
manager with the telephone company at
the time yeah which was still one of the
baby bells
and and back in those days and so it was
a very comfortable existence but there
wasn't really any
uh we never talked about finance around
the table um
uh we didn't we didn't
they didn't set up investment accounts
for my sister and i right so there
wasn't really any kind of impetus coming
out of the house
um when i went to
college
i uh
i started as actually as a political
science major because i wanted to go to
law school yep and it's because we
needed we needed more lawyers absolutely
yeah absolutely
and and um i i sort of got disabused of
that notion and then woke up one day and
said hey i want to be an economist
instead
i have no good answer for why that
happened but it did and and that kind of
put me on the path that that i have been
on for the last
really 40 years i guess
after grad school so that took you to
the land of corn
it did and so you were you go from being
popcorn in particular popcorn and potato
that's right that's right a specific
kind of corn that's that's in indiana
which i spend a lot of time in with my
boys at culver
um
five minutes from the ocean
you know a low of zero tonight a little
bit of a weather transition
to go get to west lafayette indiana so
so again this is where i
also have no good explanation for how a
kid that grew up five minutes from the
beach in san diego uh-huh got to west
lafayette you know in those days um
travel wasn't as common air travel in
particular you
we didn't i had never seen the campus
before i actually had committed to going
there really um no because it it just
wasn't campus tours wasn't yeah why this
was pre-internet i didn't even see
pictures of it really other than what
they sent in brochures right
and so it was a bit of a leap of faith
part of it was the idea that my goal was
was actually to get back to san diego
um after i got my graduate degree and
and so there was more of you know
frankly
graduate schools like um ucla and
berkeley on the on the west coast
graduates from there were kind of a dime
a dozen
and and so there was more of a mystique
going out of out of state and
particularly somehow east of the rockies
was that was the barrier where people
from california had trouble imagining
what was on the other side of that in
those days so well i went there with the
intention of getting back to san diego
which happened for a few years before i
ended up here
well and i came you know
living here in austin for two years in
1996 i was one of the many people who
really wanted to get a job in austin
and stay here but that that didn't
happen um because wall street's not in
austin
now it's venture capital and private
equity and i mean this is a financial
hub today so one thing one thing that
austin
has always had
is the um
institutional investments you know
associated with the state whether it be
the the university system utemko you
mentioned
or teacher retirement system there's an
employee retirement system there are
other state systems
so it's always been
a little bit of a of a hotbed or at
least a microcosm of asset management
but nothing like what we've seen oh gosh
develop over the last 25 years yeah it's
it's it is remarkable you would be able
to have a wall street career here now
without going to new york
well you were don't you think don't you
think and i i tell my students this all
the time
there's still um
that that i'll use old language here but
that good housekeeping seal of approval
on your resume of actually working
within new york on wall street without a
doubt your intention is to trade up or
trade sideways
you know when i when i left wall street
i signed a non-compete i agreed to leave
the industry i had completely changed
industries because after being on wall
street on wall street
i couldn't imagine
leaving the buzz
no i just i couldn't and i'd gotten a
second master's by then so i knew what i
wanted to do when i really grew up i
wanted to write for a living and then i
ended up being a central banker somehow
i don't how did that happen i don't know
i actually know richard fisher called me
but
it
i mean i could not imagine once i once
you get to new york
and you get the fever from being on the
trading floor there's just there's
nothing like it
anywhere
um
but that was that that was back then so
um well i think you knew this but i um
before we met i had i had come
to austin to teach right back in the mid
80s and after four years or so i took a
leave and i went to work on wall street
so how was that oh it was great it was
great but but but it it was great in in
several ways it's it
it's an absolutely intoxicating
environment
it's great i i work in a building now
and my colleagues are are
amazingly smart and and we have great
conversations on a daily basis that was
certainly true
in working on the street you know you
walk into
to the building and and i was at what's
now jp morgan it was manufacturers
hanover at the time manny henne and and
it's just full of smart people and it's
just a very stimulating environment
well so you were there during the crash
of 87 i was
in fact a funny story about that
i was there very many funny ones
i took a i took a
leave and i was kind of on the fence
whether i wanted to come back to
academia and do kind of more of the
research thing you know as a professor
or stay working on wall street
and on
the the day of the crash
i was eating with a
lunch at the yale club with a head
hunter
wow and it was about it was for a job
with a quant hedge fund oh wow and we
had this is before hedge funds were a
thing yeah and and so that that that was
the spin on this it was kind of this
exotic new position
and um
he went uh got up and went to the
restroom during lunch and came in and
the yale
had one of those old
bubble topped uh ticker
oh yes yes yes yes yes yes and this guy
came back and he his face was ashen and
he said
you know the market's down 200. yeah
which which yeah that was a 23.4 decline
yeah and and well it became that at the
end of the day yeah and um so we had a
very nice lunch and talked about the job
and then of course we know what happened
after that and then the
the guy called back a couple days later
and said well
unfortunately uh the job is not there
anymore
uh because the firm's not there anymore
they were they may have thought of
themselves as hedge but they realized
they had some exposures that uh well i
mean this was uh you know famously
ten years or so later we had long-term
capital management yeah with a lot of
really smart people that had to get
bailed out uh by alan greenspan and
all the banks except for
let me think lehman brothers and bear
stearns with those two exceptions
everybody else wrote the check
funny how that works
you know i teach uh
one of one of the the joys of what i do
now is i i get to create some of my own
courses and i'm teaching a course right
now but just finishing up this semester
called finance fiction in film
and and what it is is a kind of a
mash-up of of talking to
these honors
students at the university
about um finance concepts you know just
in some
most of them are not business majors so
it's just here's how stocks work here's
how bond here's what traders do
but then also um
read novels you know like the bonfire of
the vanity oh yeah which was from my
time when i was there
uh cosmopolis is another one that we
look at
um
but but but starting to go off in the
tangent no no no this is fascinating the
the
what what i i love about that so the
idea is to is to look at finance and
economic issues through the prism of how
authors and filmmakers look at this and
kind of convey this information to
to real folks out there outside the
academy it's such a hot area right now
because i mean you can you've got
billions but after the crisis
there were all these wonderful movies
that were made yes well in margin call
for instance is one i think margin calls
the most realistic of the
movie great acting in it what i was
going to say danielle is is one thing
that that really pops when you start
looking at
the things i talk about in class every
day from a conceptual and theoretical
level but but look at them from from
through the prism of somebody from the
outside and thinking about how actual
people are affected by these events
the one thing that these great writers
and filmmakers really hone in on in
terms of a financial concept is the idea
of leverage
and and mostly
how leverage is used for evil rather
than good right well and and so
we we talk at length about the long-term
capital situation where they were
levered up what probably 33 oh gosh
which was exactly what the the banks
were able to do during the 08 crisis
right
famously what bear stearns lehman
brothers you know what got him in
trouble is
they had 97 cents of debt for every
dollar of assets and then they put their
dollar of assets into
40 cents of that dollar into the these
very toxic tranches
of
these cdos anything collateralized yes
anything collateralized and then
collateralizing the collateralization oh
the synthetic clo i'm not
like oh that's
i was not there when when everything
turned synthetic i was at credit suisse
uh for the very first ever
collateralized mortgage obligation on
the street
yep i was i was in the room and i
stupidly raised my hand and i said who
buys the equity tranche
who's that stupid and in the end of
course
that was the hottest ticket everybody
wanted that equity tranche because
that's what happens when you know
speculation goes wild so
kind of like an nft for somebody's
thought that like sells for four hundred
thousand dollars
um
so what what what what did make you
choose to come back
except for the fact that this is austin
and it is it is the university of texas
there's that and and what i what i found
is um
well i i was fortunate in the sense that
that after i i was i guess i
we lived and i worked you know
physically in new york for about a year
and a half
but the bank had continuing needs for
for
me to work for them
partly as a consultant but partly uh as
an educator you know just you know
talking to their bankers
and doing that not only in new york but
around the world
and and so
that
kind of launched me into a 20-year
relationship with the bank where
i got to
to live here and work at the university
but go off
to really all parts of the world they
had they had operations in
virtually all continents i didn't get to
all of them but but most of them
and um
plus i would get back to new york
you know four or five times a year sure
which was great i loved it but once
you've lived there it's fun to go back
but for yes but it was also great to get
on a plane
four or five times a year and come back
to boston you know so
there there's uh
there's there's
trade-offs you make when you live as you
know when you live in new york and even
when you visit new york but we love it
there and so i i kind of
felt like i stumbled into the best of
both worlds you did clearly
and i'm
i'm i'm laughing because
of the of all of the professors that i
had
at the business school
my the two that made an impact
had worked in the real world
and
you know as being a veteran of the fed
with
phds
few of whom have ever had experience
in the real world i mean you draw that
contrast and
then you see why the fed's in such a
pickle
is because they're they're they're
moving solely off of whatever the
dissertation was that was written i mean
my mentor at the fed harvey rosenblum
he retired after being 40 years at the
fed he was the director of research
under richard fisher
and when he was retiring
he said my biggest regret is that
i've been here for 40 years and i
haven't encouraged all of these
academics
to
to conduct research to help make
monetary policy they just come to the
fed and continue on with whatever their
dissertation was about pretty much for
the rest of their careers
and i'm like well that that's not very
pragmatic or productive he said well no
um
but
talk about the importance of bringing
the real world
into the classroom especially in
something like a business school
sure um
i never considered myself all right i i
got
out of high school i went right to
college
i went straight into grad school so i
was 25 when i when i came out with my
phd which is young
these days wow wow it's hard to get one
much earlier than that in fact um
but i had no experience in the real
world
uh no experience in business
and and so
i wasn't even sure i wanted to go into
academia
right at first but one thing i figured
out pretty quickly
is that it isn't exactly a two-way
street you can you can always leave
an academic position and go to work for
a wall street firm or a money management
firm
but if you come out of grad school and
start
outside of academia it's very hard to
get back in
for the simple reason that in some sense
you never know
as much about the the the great breadth
of all the topics that you you study
as the day you leave graduate school so
if i'd gone off and worked for a money
management firm for say four years and
then said i think i'd rather go back to
the academy and teach and do research
they would just go out and get something
i wouldn't have any experience or maybe
any publications
to my name and my phd would then be four
years out of date right so they would
just go get somebody who's freshly
minted right
so so that's why i mean it's not a
two-way street i wasn't really sure but
i said well i better start in academia i
never considered myself in the early
years to be an irrelevant professor
i worked hard to try to to to make sure
that the theories and concepts that
we're talking about you know i showed
him the practical side as well
but a lot of that was just secondhand
because i hadn't experienced that myself
when i went to
in fact one of my mantras is
is theory and practice you know when i
teach
i i i firmly believe nothing puts you in
a better position
in your career
as a student than than having a very
good theoretical or conceptual
foundation sure for understanding how
things work
but it's essential can't end there right
it can't no no it's got to be about how
you apply it right so what what going to
wall street really helped me understand
was
that it isn't um
it isn't about the elegance of the
solution it's it's really about
understanding the nature of the problem
and then figuring out what it takes to
solve it like like you were you were in
the derivatives class yes we taught
which we we rebranded
instead of i think in those days it used
to be called something awkward like a
seminar in futures and options or
something that sounds familiar yeah not
very familiar after 25 years but it
sounds vaguely familiar now we call it
financial risk management because at
some point we just recognized that you
know futures and options are important
and you need to understand how they work
but ultimately they're just tools
they're they're they're hedging their
hammers and nails yeah and and like any
tool you can you can use it to build a
beautiful building or you can
you know smack somebody over the head
with it right right so it can be used
for good or evil and and so
understanding why you're doing it is is
gonna make that what's right or wrong
and you go in and that relates to the
leverage conversation we had a second
ago is leverage
nothing
is a more beautiful example of how
finance can work for the good when you
use it right i mean think about we were
just talking about
you know the the mortgage crisis but the
reality is you know what maybe one
percent of the people
in the country could afford to buy a
home if they had to pay cash yeah right
so people lever up all the time and that
that massively improves the quality of
their life if done properly but then we
have plenty of examples and in fact very
recent examples well the federal reserve
just came out um and announced that that
because of the archagos blow up
that that they're going to have to have
greater transparency into
what the hedging operations are what you
know how much
leverage they have spread across
different prime brokers and because if
you're
if you're if you're using collateral in
six different places yeah same
collateral and six different places to
lever up
it's
apparently can go wrong very quickly
the yeah indeed and and and especially
if if you get lacks
regulation that that doesn't even pay
attention or or promotes it or
understand yeah well okay there's that
too yeah yeah i mean i'll never forget i
was at the fed during the flash crash
and we never figured it out yeah to this
day it's still not well understood i
mean theoretically there was one big
money manager in the midwest who sold a
bunch of options
but
but but the daisy chain
yeah was never fully
understood
by the regulators because we were the
regulators
so it's pretty remarkable
so you come back
and then you're traveling all around the
world
uh how between classes i should you know
i never i never once missed a class
i didn't miss any of your classes either
so
i missed although i had a very odd
schedule in those days and i think
you must have been part of this too
but i i taught monday friday classes
yeah
and and which which um
i don't know you guys probably thought
of me as satan because you had to come
to class on both monday and friday
morning well i was working at the career
i was working at the career center at
the time so i had to be honest i also
know for you guys thursday nights were
sacred those were thinking
and uh
those darn morning classes were probably
those crazy boys from the midwest and
they would never have taken your class
because those rugby players engineering
undergrads they were like hell no on a
friday morning class
it was worth it though i mean trust me
it was worth it because so so some of my
traveling was kind of squeezed in
in you know i'd finish up classes on
monday yup and then fly off to new york
do a few days in new york and then come
back
but you were at the university when
effectively
uh
the investment
actual investing was
was introduced
a trading floor oh the the that's right
in fact the i was there when they were
building it i was uh i was
the guy who ran i think you're talking
about the nba investments yes where yes
we were there i was trying eds it's
because the company is no longer with us
that's why i couldn't remember the eds
is the one who sponsored they sponsored
the whole trading complex and the
the student managed investment fund was
part of that yeah yeah that that was
that was interesting i i had a lot of
fun with that for for a long time
um
one of my colleagues who's passed away
uh uh sadly by now george gao and i
george
oh my gosh i started there
and george um was really the guy that
worked with the investors if you
remember the the hook on that was there
were there are a lot of universities
that
that have a student-managed investment
program but usually they get a piece of
the endowment
and it's it's almost like donated
capital what what we did was set up an
llc and actually
get investor money so we we had more of
like a mutual fund model
and it got in its heyday
it got to over 30 million dollars and so
it was a lot of fun we had three
different investment strategies that the
students would manage and and i was the
the guy who kind of put together the
infrastructure for that and along with
the students of course but then but then
ran it for
a number of years and then i had uh
good colleagues come along and follow me
like sandy leeds i think you know and uh
you know he and i worked on it for
several years and so you look up and i
think that's been in business now for
27 years
oh gosh because i was that would have
been my first year was 94 when they were
building it so that would be 27.
now we've gone from 25 to 27. we're
going in the wrong direction keith
i'm routing you here
um so how has
how is teaching i have to ask this
question how is teaching finance
changed on a fundamental level
since the fed
put was born
in terms of
fundamental analysis
you know i mean people always ask me
what was your hardest class in business
school and i'm like managerial
accounting i can immediately say it and
you're really it's like a six
six hour course one of the best
professors i've ever had i mean you have
a true appreciation you have to have an
accounting backbone if you're going to
be in finance
you absolutely have to be able to read a
balance sheet and a profit and loss
statement
but how has
how is teaching
finance in a world where fed policy
slowly degrades
price discovery and where passive
investing has a similar effect so how
has that changed how you teach well uh
so in finance we can kind of break the
discipline into uh the the buy side in
the sell side corporations you know what
they do with all this and i'm on the
investment and portfolio management side
and um the biggest change for me
is uh i used to love to talk about fixed
income investing because you mentioned
one of the
the the consulting practices i have on
the side is
a fulcrum financial group which
uh along with a partner of mine we
managed bond portfolios for for clients
for 30 years
um nobody wants to talk about fixed
income investing anymore
you know when when rates are zero
unless you kind of convince them that
rates can go negative and you can point
around the world to a couple of
instances but
um it's it's just not a not for the next
four years with jay powell yeah oh yeah
yeah um
so and that's interesting too because in
the work i do with with the
institutional investors here in austin
the teacher retirement system a big
defined benefit pension plan as well as
utemco
which by the way that's been rebranded
you may not have known this it's it's
now officially the university of texas
slash texas a m
investment management company
oh my god about the aggies about a third
of the assets goodness about a third of
the assets in there and they have gosh
it's probably
well over 60 billion at this point but
about a third of their assets belong to
the texas a m system
and it all comes back from the
you may know the history of
how the system got to be
rich is is that
when the university
was first started back in the 1800s
the legislature knew it had to endow
the the university with some assets to
keep it you know self-sustaining but at
the time the valuable land in texas was
all the timber out in the eastern part
of the state along the louisiana border
and they didn't want to give it any of
that so they said well let's just give
it out some of that stuff out way out in
west texas
which you know within 40 50 years was
black gold black old yeah and and so the
money
has been coming into the university of
texas and then at some point a m got cut
in on that as well um
but yeah the board that that uh i'm you
know privileged to serve as an advisor
um
a third of it are a m
people regents or or other people
connected with with the a m side i did
not and the other the two thirds are ut
related but uh anyway
as a result of that i i'll tell you it's
interesting
in some ways
it's made the story a little bit more
interesting in class
because
the the way i launch i i try to again
lay that conceptual foundation so so i
start
every class um
you know just saying all right
here are a few bedrock ideas you know
what what investors do how they get paid
um you know what they can expect to get
paid and just go through things like
that
and
at the simplest level as an investor you
can either be a lender
or you can be an owner
and own companies like the stock owned
private companies own assets
most of the risk in investing is in
ownership not in lending
in fact with with
lending to the government ostensibly you
know risk-free
so
organizations like a utemco or a teacher
retirement system
they have bills to pay
think about the the pension fund you
know they have to pay the retirement
benefits for their current retirees and
all those future ones
so they have a fairly prescribed list of
liabilities and and they calculate it
roughly at somewhere in the range of
seven to seven and a half percent
nominal a year
so that's what they have to earn
in order not to be liquidating their
portfolio right
back in the day you know even before
when when we met
you could get you could pay your bills
by being a lender which is obviously the
preference because if if i can pay my
bills with the least amount of risk yeah
i'm going to do it if you if you can
clip a 7.5
and contingent ladders you know we had a
lot of fixed income based strategies
you know because you could get paid
enough to to actually pay your bills
can't do that anymore
so so the biggest thing
about
both what i talk about in the classroom
but also when i when i work with you
know the institutional investors here
the biggest thing that happened
in you know starting in 2008
was when you when you
make when you take rates to zero
basically people can't get paid to be
lenders
and of course that was the whole point
right they wanted the money engaged they
wanted it at risk right of course
they wanted people to
is then institutions that in their asset
allocation scheme which is all about
trying to find the right amount of risky
and riskless assets to to you know solve
your problem which is to pay your bills
um they had to shift more and more of
their allocation out of fixed income
into equities
and and then at some point public
equities weren't paying enough so what
we've really seen and and this is
why it's interesting just in a different
way than i used to talk about all this
is now we see so much money flooding
into private market investments
alternatives and and and you you talked
about people not understanding you know
collateral arrangements and buried
leverage and you know i'm not sure
people understand liquidity risk
no
and we spoke about this a few days ago
no they don't
and in fact
i find it to be a little disconcerting
that they're coming up with retail
products
with private equity i i might wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute we we
used to have to have qualified investors
in order to invest in these very
illiquid
and yet
very pro-cyclical as well
entities and people don't realize that
when public equities
you know if the junk bond market closes
and you can't do ipos and
that that liquidity risk becomes
amplified
you know danielle
what's really interesting about that too
is that the motivation is
the belief you're going to get paid more
dale swenson years ago in in
the the you know
he's the godfather of private equity up
at yale gosh he had a a great chart i
still use in class in in one of yale's
annual reports that showed a
side-by-side comparison
of peer group comparisons and different
asset classes
you know what the range of returns were
and who's in the first quartile second
quartile and so on
well if you line them up and you put um
either vc venture capital or or buy out
you know type private equity
uh side by side with you know like uh
small cap
um
public equities right if you're not
above the
median as a manager in private equity
you're not going to outperform
public equity which means you're going
to be tying up all that capital for
years
and you're not going to get paid a
liquidity premium for it so so the the
problem is that we have we've seen just
a profit amount of money
out of institutions rushing into private
markets and now like you say in the
retail space as well
most of those people are going to walk
away really disappointed oh and and then
if there's a liquidity event on top of
that
you're going to see
it go well beyond disappointment and
into you know heartbreak and misery and
a lot of stuff and i just i i don't um
it's become such a massive cottage
industry yeah and
you know the pension you know advising
pensions has become so
rote
that
it's like you have to be in
alternatives and there are a few there
are a few pensions that have said no
recently and there was a big scandal
they asked calpers
i'm not sure when this was 18 months two
years ago they asked calpers if if
calpers could define how much they were
spending on fees for private equity
funds and they couldn't come up with an
answer
which was
scandalous and shocking
but it's it's i mean when you think
about your your
private equity funds they want to raise
cash
and they get to charge on that cash
whether it's deployed or not
it's no wonder steven schwartzman's you
know
annual income is is you know
a multiple of a building the the
and and it's not stopping either no
we've seen we you know the capital
raising
yeah it's it's um
and so much of this is being funded
out of institutional budgets
and you know i've studied the asset
allocation for endowments and some of
the research i've done
and um
you got to pay for all that from
somewhere
and and it's it's really
interesting you know we we use terms
particularly with the institutional
institutional investors of risk a risk
budget
and and so what what
boards
at a utemco or a texas teacher
retirement system will do
is essentially approve a certain amount
of risk that that the managers of the
fund can take
and so a risk budget okay i'm learning
this budgeting yeah that's that's kind
of a hot area now
and we you know
the whole risk management area that's
that would be a fascinating topic of
discussion for you as well because
in
not too long ago what people really
meant when they said risk
management was really more risk
measurement it was almost more an audit
function
it's just like let's just see how much
risk we had and did we get paid value at
risk and blah blah blah but but now that
area is being integrated more and more
into the actual portfolio uh
management process you know starting
with the asset allocation piece and then
even you know how we design uh our
portfolios whether we concentrate or
expand you know yeah it's becoming much
more of a management tool than just sort
of an audit that's good news so because
you should be off you know you should
play offense not defense
but yes
um and and and they are and and it's you
know because it's
if you think about this progression i
was laying out before we would like to
pay our seven and a half percent bill
that we have due every year
by
keeping it as safe as possible by being
a lender but we can't right so now we're
going to switch into ownership and
owning primarily equities
um and even public market equities
aren't good enough so now we're going
into private market equities and keep
kind of pushing farther out
out at the curve with doing that but
it was interesting on how we decided to
pay for all that
we didn't take the money out of other
equities and go into just private forms
we ran down our fixed income budgets
and and so you know for instance a
couple of the institutions i work with
actually don't have a standing
allocation to credit risky fixed income
securities at all wow so their only
fixed income allocation is on on
treasuries well they're so so risky
credit
and private equity are
so highly correlated
well there's that and and again it's
just a practical reality if you're going
to take if you're going to take the risk
try to get paid for it
and so the institutions that that i
work with
again i've mentioned a couple of times
the the pension fund and the endowment
have been able to uh
forge
relationships and partnerships with some
of the
the reliably top
private equity firms and that's the
thing i mean
at this point they have to be the
biggest it has to be yeah and
certainly above the median
in terms of performance over time and
and it's getting the point where even
you have to be first quartile to justify
that
risk premium you know most of the
analysis that
that i see and i've i've been associated
with
you know argues that you probably need
to get about 300 to 500 basis points of
return to justify how long you're tying
up your money mm-hmm and this is from
universities that if you think about
the things that would be more like a
liquidity premium
they are
they're not going to expire you know god
willing university of texas will be
there forever
and and so they're a very long-term
player which means that the football
team can eventually come back
you know what you hope
yeah don't get me going on that too but
i i've been here long enough to
appreciate some success but i was here
when ricky williams was here i mean that
was that was great that was good that
was great and vince shortly vincent
after that gosh
anyway anyway yeah
the rose bowl so uh but what it sounds
like what you were describing is more
like a liquidity premium
yeah and and if you're not getting that
it's probably not worth tying up your
money and the point is
you're not most people in this market
are not going to get that
and and and that's why it
i understand
just the way product
you know proliferation works on wall
street that you come out with retail
versions of this but it's not a retail
game you know you know we both know that
and and
and so
the the irony because we saw the same
thing with
retail versions of hedge funds packaged
as mutual funds they figured out how to
charge hedge fund like fees right what
they didn't figure out is how to deliver
hedge fund like performance exactly and
i think the same thing's going to happen
on the retail side and private equity
yeah i mean when i was when i when i was
at dlj i mean you know tony james and
leon black and schwartzman i mean dlj
has some serious because we had a
merchant bank
we were private equity before private
equity was a thing
and to see
just the
the growth trillions and trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars of
dry powder is just
it's it's unreal
and then you hear a blackstone come out
and say well there's nothing we can buy
and yet they keep raising more and more
money
you know that's a great point
because that's exactly right it's you
know they they complain about how how
multiples have expanded you know uh
eevee but multiples which is what they
look at mainly and yeah they're they're
they're paying 14 15 times i mean
astronomical as opposed to what not too
long ago
six to eight oh yeah
you were always supposed to be in a
single digits right
and and and that's where you're and then
you buy them
you buy them cheapler you're supposed to
buy them that's the point their
operations and flip them exactly there's
your value proposition i mean that was
that was the movie wall street but took
it back to this you know the course that
you which we were made to watch the
first day of the training
um nba training program at tlj
by the way another movie that i actually
show in my finance fiction and film
class i i don't i show them clips of
wall street because everyone has to see
the
greatest good speech of course gordon
gekko
but but but a better movie that covers
the same ground as other people's money
which which you you might have seen it
as it was a stage play in new york
before it became a movie yeah and it's
sort of a silly rom-com with danny
devito of all people as the yeah as the
you know the romantic lead
um but but it asks serious questions
about you know what the role of
corporate raiders are and
and and uh you know what what the
function of a corporation who a
corporation
should serve are they just about uh
maximizing shareholder value as guys
like me saying classrooms
or
should they be protecting workers taking
care of the community and and the whole
esg movement that we've seen oh gosh
has been all about that has recognized
you have other stakeholders besides just
the governance aspect
well governance certainly yeah
and and that's of the of those three
letters
in terms of what really hits the bottom
line in terms of of prices it's it's
really the g
it's the governance getting you know
getting alignment on on governance yeah
i mean being being on wall street when
enron blew up you know
you you learned about governance
you learned about boards that were not
governing yeah and um
but it it
it it concerns me that there's so much
dry powder out there it concerns me that
there's never been as i mean all these
cranes around us right now and there's
there's never been more dry powder to to
pour into commercial real estate and
private debt is a new thing and we're
talking about this is something that's
racial big new thing it's it's a
trillion dollar new thing so so
it's up to a trillion dollars in the in
the endowment um
won't do
credit risky public debt
but they'll do private debt
you know because they feel they get paid
at that if they get the right if they
get the right uh
lp structure and yeah that they can
participate in boy
this is some racy stuff i mean this is
this is more riskier than a leveraged
loan or a junk bond or
potentially
i mean that i think i think that that's
the main distinction is that
people don't understand that coming to
the pandemic
corporate america was more levered up
than it had ever been and that was kind
of a known known
but small and medium enterprises were
twice as levered up as their largest
counterparts
and
and that has proliferated in a
post-pandemic world because now it's we
went straight back down to the zero
bound
yeah so it just poured fuel on the fire
because all we had was a you know a
two-month flash recreation recession
that was over
before it began and we've had the
most magnificent rally in the history of
the united uh like the the whole stock
market yeah in the shortest span of time
well um
money being free helped right oh
and i'll tell you another thing that's
been interesting to talk about in class
for
most of the last century
it
just a mantra that we would preach
is that value investing dominates growth
investing
that controlling what you pay on the
front end is better than buying into the
sizzle of the story on where growth is
going to come and that is such a passion
until ten years ago yes and now it
hasn't been because
the biggest beneficiaries on the equity
side have been the growth stocks
well and that's got rates too that's
that's fed by the 2006 law change that's
what they wanted right
that requires human resources
departments to put their employees into
target date funds
so it's and they rebalance every quarter
so every quarter if the stock market
falls they've got a rebalance back up
and you know
the biggest
one of the funds at vanguard the total
stock index fund is 1.3 trillion dollars
so
i've learned a lot from from some very
smart people in passive investing on
march the 23rd
when 2020 when stocks had completely
melted down and the fed came in and and
rescued the they did the bond market
bailout effectively
and grandfathered in triple b's a lot
quicker than 08 i i think a lot of
people still don't understand how but i
mean having been a veteran of the fed
for
for nine years
there was a task there was a task force
that was assigned
um
after
christmas eve 2018.
so that was a plan that they had that
they'd been working on for a very you
don't get academics and bureaucrats to
launch something that extensive had they
not been thinking about it since late
with the powell pivot
uh so that was but but anyways march the
23rd 2020 here comes the fed
with the guns loaded yeah
and
the target date
funds
that have had their you know the portion
of the the 60 let's say it's a 40 year
old worker the 60 of their equity
allocation
has been decimated so march the 23rd was
the
rebalancing date
so
trillions of dollars flowed into the
stock market
index funds the biggest growth names
and it's it's it's this law change that
human resources
managers are required to
to put
any investor who does not say after a
30-day period
that you know how they want to allocate
their own 401k then the law of the
united states says then you must put it
in a target date fund
and so the monster of passive investing
once this gained steam after 2006
passive investing is now
it feeds on itself
fascinating along with a
colleague and good friend of mine a guy
named van holler who is at fidelity
investments we've done a fair bit of
research on in this area and one thing
that's fascinating to me if if you look
under the hood of a target a series of
target date funds with the same target
date they have wildly different
glide paths in terms of what their asset
allocation strategies are so even what
they're rebalancing too
are very different
so it's it's it's you know that
laws like what you just talked about are
really
designed in part on on the idea that
these are almost commodities that if you
pick a
a target date that's right for you
and whether you go to vanguard or
fidelity or whoever you're going to get
a fairly similar product you're not
they're they're very different and so it
kind of dovetails into something i've
been thinking a lot about
um and that's the idea of financial
literacy and and of course you know
that's why you're sitting here today by
the way that's the whole mission of down
the middle it's pure financial literacy
i i work well i know that's uh preaching
the choir on that but
the the um
the
i work for a defined benefit pension
plan for the board
but
those are fairly rare entities these
days particularly in the corporate world
and of course the whole idea of going to
define contribution plans like a 401k
if a company has it at all
is
a hundred percent just to shift the risk
for the investment outcome
from their books right as the company on
to the investor absolutely but investors
largely are not prepared
no i don't think that they understand
uh and
this is probably the the key element of
financial literacy is
kind of in high school-ish before you
get your first job is to convey that
that
momentum is fickle
and you know the feds
the fed put has never failed in a
passive world the fed's always been able
to come in
with the liquidity um but i don't i
don't think that your average target
date fund
investor
would probably understand that momentum
can move in a different direction
because it never has
as far as i mean most most living most
people in finance have been in you know
their entire careers have been
surrounded by falling interest rates
well the the point of one of the
research articles that that van and i
did was we we documented we think that
a lot of the target date funds were over
allocated to equities for the purpose of
of the retirees
um
and and you know the the paper was kind
of about showing that that's how we got
into the the idea of target date funds
but
the
the i i think it's a it's a fascinating
area and it's not going away you know in
terms of
of just trying to get people to think
more you know it's funny in fact
we were talking about the the bond
portfolios that i managed um i sort of
fancied myself for for that period of
time as a money manager but what i
realized pretty quickly um
especially with a bond fund we weren't a
very active manager so most days
you know i may
annoy some of your your viewers with
this characterization but most days
being a bond manager
was a lot like watching paint dry on a
wall you know you bought bonds and yeah
you you bought them for a purpose they
you got checks periodically and you just
wait to get the checks sure so so most
days what i really was was a client
manager
and it was really about managing client
expectations
educating the client
um it wasn't really about the money per
se that was well taken care of and
invested and it was clearly automated
but but
clients particularly on the wealth
management side
are
have lots of needs and wants and desires
and and
and uh heuristic biases that they're
subject to and so
you know they they uh they need they
need to be educated and and that that
often comes to the money manager but
then if if incentives aren't aligned
in terms of even how the manager's
getting paid they don't have the
incentive to provide that education
right no and and so things like
mandating that people being a target
fund that's sort of a heavy-handed
version of
richard thaler's old nudge concept where
we'll yeah you can make your own
decision but if you don't we're going to
push you wherever you think you should
be
and now it becomes kind of a
self-feeding mechanism
and you you have to wonder how
how this all
plays out i mean we
i have no idea you
nobody knows none of us know
um
retail investors
i mean this is this is a wild time to be
teaching finance
i mean really what between the
the chat rooms and the cryptocurrencies
and
nfts and spax
meme stocks
i mean we've got
massive retail participation right now
that we haven't seen
really since the dot com days
yes and and um
it it's hard to rationally explain like
gamestop
i mean it's it's it's if you've ever
taken portfolio management 101 you can't
it's wildly fun to talk about oh gosh
yeah just the idea of a bear squeeze and
just just the
the the
kind of common man
beating the oh yeah this is this is
david versus yes huge i mean go take
that big big headphones great story but
it's impossible
to rationalize but but then i it's hard
for me to
to talk rationally about like the price
of tesla say you know as well it you
know if you just try to break it down on
fundamentals no i mean that's what i'm
saying for certain that's another uh
good example you know that
the private equity crowd kind of likes
them because it gives them a vehicle for
selling some of their
of course portfolio companies but
it's it's a fairly scary proposition but
but it's also one that for investors
it's almost like they have a free option
i don't know just i think we were
talking about this the other day
um the the spac that was going to take
buzzfeed
public and their investors didn't like
that apparently and was it like a 95
withdrawal oh gosh uh of funds
and so it's a bit of a free option at
that level but i i think there's a
disconnect
um
it's already cooling off it appears to
be oh gosh yes i mean
once once the onion was peeled back i
think and
and people realized that these were kind
of glorified one-time dividends being
paid to
to the people who who formed this back
and that they had no downside and that
the investors had all of the dance wait
a minute wait a minute where's the
incentive structure
here but but it you know the the the
story was look this is a more efficient
way to get a company public without
going through the
the whole underwriting process in the
normal you know ipo
but you know i've always been a little
surprised that direct listings haven't
been
more of a tool that people use we've
seen we've seen just a handful of them
these last just a handful and and i
think maybe one of the problems is it's
difficult to actually raise funds in the
event you know when you come public so
that has to be done separately and maybe
maybe that's enough to to throw people
off the
you know you know
off that notion but um
spacks are just i think are fascinating
so all of that's really interesting to
talk about what's hard is to kind of put
that in in in that
coherent world view i was talking about
no i mean your foundation the conceptual
foundation has no place and that's why
i'm saying it's it's
an active management is you know
discounted cash flow models so so much
that used to matter
it seems like it's irrelevant
okay so
now i'm going to have to take exception
because i'm old school enough where
this kind of cash flow still does matter
and and i'm happy you're pushing back
i'm happy you're pushing back not all
the time you know again we can't
we just gave two examples yeah game stop
and then and then tesla it's hard to
make a
kind of a coherent dcf story out of
um
but but i think uh public markets
are generally very efficient you know
one trend we've we've seen
that i find fascinating i've i've some
of my research is in this area as well
is um
startup companies are staying private a
lot longer than they used to right i
mean it used to be
especially in the tech space it might be
what three years from launch to ipo now
it's more than 10 typically
and and a lot of it is this
trend toward institutional investing
flooding
money into
you know the the dry powder you were
talking of course
and and so that's enabling companies to
stay private longer
if there wasn't value in staying private
from the company's standpoint
in terms of
you know better
you know we were talking about
governance alignment you know better
governance alignment better
organizational alignment just being out
of the public eye not having to hit
quarterly hurdles right in terms of and
that's enormous paul
there's a real benefit to companies if
they can grow
and still stay private absolutely
that that fostered this whole unicorn
phenomenon right which is now
now we're talking about decacorns you
know uh
getting to be 10 billion right right of
value you know and staying private
one thing that's done
is it's significantly reduced the number
of public companies we have
the wilshire five thousand is no longer
five thousand five thousand yeah we
don't have five thousand pounds
yeah
yeah yeah and and and we um and it's
particularly hit small cap
though the small cap space there really
isn't enough to buy so so now most
managers i work with don't even refer to
small cap they
they they refer to the smid class you
know they they combine small and mid
small and mid yeah just so they have
enough things to buy in that space right
and and and so
i think that's one of the things that
fueled the this back phenomenon is this
desire to get publix
companies public again
and but but again as soon as people kind
of figured out the value proposition
wasn't really in their favor mm-hmm um
you know the order started cooling sure
um so i'm gonna i'm gonna read something
to you
uh from fed up
if i can read this here
i thank you dr keith brown for
introducing me to the wonders and
discipline of finance during my business
school days the university of texas i
officially forgive you for dragging me
through the long hand derivation of the
black scholes model you were right it
helped build my character
so thank you again
there is a lot of trading going on right
now in options
retail trading
unforeseen levels of of options are
being traded by retail investors i
really think they should all have to go
to your class and derive the black
shells model and have a little bit
better appreciation for what they're
doing
so there are
there again this is at a broad level
there are three ways you can create
leverage you know the obvious one is
just to borrow cash
the second way is to borrow something
else and sell it to create the cash you
want you know you want to invest that's
what we call short sales yeah and the
third are derivatives
where the leverage is embedded right so
with with with a
two dollar option i can control the
destiny if that's not too grand the term
of a 50 stock yeah so it's as if i've
borrowed 48
to buy the stock right it's all about
the leverage
it's all about the leverage and and so
we're in a risk-on environment still oh
my gosh and so this is not a surprise
that especially at the retail level
um
because as as public markets have gotten
more efficient we we've also seen a
trend particularly on the retail side to
in to the more passive investing like
you were talking about
you know i i'm a proponent of of active
management
but
the reality is
two out of five managers
uh say in equities can beat the s can
beat the benchmark yeah but if you can
find those two it's worth it well yeah
and
god rest is sold tobias lefkovich
interviewed he was the chief strategist
at city for 20 years and he did his
first long-form interview on this show
on down the middle before he died
shortly before he died
and one of the things he pointed out was
in the first quarter and the second
quarter uh that that there was a
substantial proportion we're talking
about like a third of the s p 500 that
outperformed
the broader index so he pushed back just
like you just pushed back because there
is a place for
looking for value and there is a place
there are
good active managers can
create alpha
uh they're out there and and you know
through the university uh system and the
pension fund you know they're able to
find them yeah
but not everyone is right no and and so
i think it's you know what one thing
i mentioned leverage is kind of a key
idea in finance another thing that
emerges is
is the real value of information
and and you know when we start talking
in in a classroom setting
we we tend to make sweeping statements
like let's assume information is
free and available to everybody
but neither of those things are true
and and so it's really all about
information and access you know frankly
beyond just being smart enough to figure
out who the
you know to to vet managers and figure
out who the good ones are
it helps to be able to write a big
enough check to get their attention too
as an investor
and and retail investors generally
don't have that in any of those
categories no no no no no and and so
that and you still have the sell side
with did it i feel like we've gone full
circle back to 1999 2000 because the the
vast vat
vast majority of calls or buys as
opposed to neutral or of course yeah so
i mean even though there was a law
change in between nothing's really
changed which has always been silly
right because how can how can somebody
put out a buy recommendation
not knowing anything about your
portfolio versus mine right and how it
fits so that that's just
on its face a silly thing to do yeah but
that's you know that's what they get
paid to do
um so i'd like to i'd like to round up
by going back to
fast times at claremont high oh
can you tell that story sure i always
like to i always like to end on a funny
happy note so let's tell that story so
so again i grew up in a in an absolutely
comfortable
middle class community in san diego
and and i went to
an absolutely
pedestrian public high school called
claremont high school
which no one's ever heard of
unless it's by its alternative title
which is ridgemont high this was the
school i love this that was the uh the
the basis for the movie the book first
and then the movie and accountants at
richmond high that's right yeah that's
right it was first a book and again the
story if
if you've heard this is
is uh that cameron crowe
was a
precocious i think he was maybe 19 at
the time he probably looked 15.
and he worked for the rolling stone
and he convinced his editors and somehow
the san diego unified school district
to let him enroll undercover under a
false name back at my high school and
then write this expose about modern high
school life and this was a couple years
after i had graduated but i still had
uh i i still knew the little brothers
and sisters of she had gone to school
with at the time
and so he wrote this this this book and
it was so shoddily
produced the book that they they called
it richmond high rather than claremont
for legal right sure grounds
but they he that it was so poorly copy
edited they slip a couple places in the
book and actually call it claremont
and and then the movie came out you know
not too long after that and uh
that the brought the world uh jess
piccoli you know sean character uh sean
penn's great character
and uh i knew a lot of spikoli's that
that's the funniest part is that
that was not fictional they were true
you know
at least the archetypes not not
necessarily all the incident but you
know one thing that's kind of funny
danielle's is that
the
camera crow went undercover to write
this expose
but everyone knew who he was
so they would just make up stories to
tell him you know thinking they were
kind of goofing on on him and then the
book came out and they're like wait a
minute i didn't do i didn't really no i
studied that night i wasn't at that
party or whatever oh
love it yeah
well um
thank you
after 25 years i i really want to thank
you i want to thank you for the
inspiration that you gave me and it
doesn't matter that when you went to the
university you can go to you can go to
new york you can go make it in new york
and uh so that that kind of uh that kind
of
of guidance is is so essential and i'm
so happy that you're still
at mccombs and you're still providing
that kind of inspiration to the next
generation of investors so thank you
well you're very excited it's my
pleasure thank you thank you take care
well i hope you enjoyed my walk down
memory lane uh
and to see how dynamically thinking dr
keith brown still is and what a gift he
is to my alma mater the university of
texas hook him uh if you enjoyed his
perspective then have a look at the
other austin series interview that i did
with dr lacey hunt who's also a phd but
a phd in economics and and see how
getting a phd can be applied in the real
world whether you're talking about
economics or finance and i think that
that's a critical thing to understand is
once you once you can understand the
concept and the practice as dr brown
said
that's it you're covered
and and you're in the real world and
you're also in academy if you choose to
be so again thank you for your time and
i look forward to the next time that we
can we can come back together down the
middle and again if you don't
if you if you don't follow my research
please go on quilletologist.com
until the next time this is danielle d
martino booth thank you
[Music]
you